I am Kamala Harris my pronouns are she
at home oh this was a few months ago
yeah blue suit yo that's the vice
president that's great I I forgot about
that there's so much funny that just
just comes back like especially during
early covid when I see it again and I'm
like wow I can't believe that was real
this video is going to include
discussions about racism and because
white I am racist classist ableist and I
probably contribute to many other
systems of marginalization that I am not
aware of all white people are racist all
men are misogynistic all cisgender
people are transphobic all members of a
majority are biased being sarcastic the
minority or press group in fact most
people are racist misogynistic
transphobic ableist Etc words like
racist misogynist this thing makes me
want to be misogynistic my God women
like Kamala Harris AOC
Ayanna Presley Omar ilhan Omar and the
rest of the squad they make me not want
to ever vote for another woman again
yeah I don't blame you there are a few
women that I already know are are an
exception to that Christy gnome the
governor in South Dakota uh she she's
pretty fantastic woman and a great
leader and a few others uh that I that I
would stand behind but these women they
have proven to be completely ineffective
every bill they sponsor goes nowhere
because it's all a bunch of woke [__]
they stand at the podium and they cackle
and cry and pound and throw Tantrums you
know why they dance AOC likes to do
dancing when people were challenging her
why is it because they're women no there
are there are some good women but you
know at good women are being going to be
overshadowed by this I'm telling you no
I know a woman I'm a woman and I'm
telling you that any woman that's
running for office is going to have to
work 10 times harder to get my vote
because I'm tired of all this [__] I'm
tired of how these women have made us
all look like incompetent fools
controversial opinion but if you have a
token white and you're hanging out with
your friend group of color
you need to ask permission from
everybody in the group to bring your
white friend like don't just bring them
ask for explicit permission from
everyone because just because you're
comfortable with them doesn't mean that
everybody is comfortable with them I
might not be in the mood to deal with
white shenanigans that day that's that's
all maybe I don't want to deal with your
Asian [__] today no it's not her Asian
[__] that I don't want to deal with it's
her dumb insane racist [__] that you are
never invited to my house because if you
ever spoke about that racist [__] in my
house I'd kick you to the [__] curb
yeah it's funny how these people are
calling white people racist and they're
posting stuff like this online ah
straight jokes and another thing it's
feeds into their ego like don't don't
let them think they're a good white
person don't don't give them that card
to use against other people please don't
do that you meet racist
just want to let you know that you're
not a good white person you're a bad
white boy bad yeah I know you meet
racist
I'll gladly tell you
looks like we've got an oppressor on our
hands
so during slavery times
slaves did not get to eat the same
things as their masters this one's just
got they got this nothing behind those
eyes just a whole lot of nothing up
there I would love for her to talk about
the actual slaves that are that exist in
China and Russia and in the Congo and
other countries and other third world
countries today actual slavery that is
real that people are suffering through
and these people are just carrying on
about something because some politician
told them to be mad about it okay go
ahead pumpkin let's say what you got to
say three times
slaves do not get to eat this thing no
[__] it was a terrible job look at the
scraps that no one wanted chitterlings
now that black people have overcome
slavery they developed a rich barbecue
culture to make up that's racist bro
what are they like watermelon you go to
the store and you buy if all white
people are racist and all white people
have privilege and all white people have
bias where where does this white lady
even get off speaking for black people I
don't know you know I don't know I don't
know I'm not allowed to have an opinion
on black people because maybe all black
people she's allowed to have an opinion
on black people because it's that
opinion maybe all black people don't
like barbecues lady you know that's kind
of racist of you to assume that me as a
white person you are actively taking
away a piece of meat that could be being
enjoyed by a survivor of ancestral these
people can't be real these people this
has to be persist but it's also
anti-semitic during the Holocaust juice
did not get to eat meat in labor camps
yeah I get if I had to take a wild guess
I'd say she's never eaten meat in her
life you could use a little meat if you
know what I mean potato soup which would
spill on their bodies burning them and
giving them infections now what am I
Nazi now drivers eat a lot of meat
brisket just let this so I have this
thing call it a little cork if you will
I have hair in my armpits I have it
there for a few reasons one lazy two the
patriarchy and three your response to
them tells me everything I need to know
about you it does it does it tells me
that I like women that actually are
clean and don't smell and keep
themselves looking respectable and not
like a psychopathic lunatic so yes if
that's what that tells my response to
her tells you about me that I like
things to be modest and clean and nice
there you go that's it that's a mean ass
haircut bro I'm not even gonna lie
weirdo F the patriarchy like do you
actually think you're hurting the
patriarchy by braiding your armpit hair
yeah she is you know she's keeping the
guys away from her she's doing a good
job of it I'm sure you know what the
funny thing is I'm sure she went on
Tinder and she swiped right into sleep
she could still find a guy she might be
a lesbian so she might not want a guy if
I did I guess if I did a while old guess
oh yeah the patriarchy she's please move
on because this woman actually makes me
feel like I'm in a horror movie like and
she's like I'm changed in the basement
somewhere and she's the one that comes
down to throw food at me do you use Neo
pronouns Neo pronouns are alternative to
gendered pronouns like hey she and more
common gender-neutral pronouns they them
they include words like Thon which comes
from the one Z Faye and many others what
did come out of me too thanks for
telling me you guys are so amazing and
the contribution to the American
literary thank you for telling me
library is just
elected word or noun they felt resonated
within an agenda and use that as their
pronounselves because I'm so disgusted
it's hard to look at this I'm trying to
listen man
remember that language is change and
adapt with use and so much language has
been believed by the lgbtq plus
Community Neo pronouns are just another
addition to the rainbow dictionary since
explanation but you're not going to look
I'm gonna explain this to you very
clearly people who use ghost go self
pronouns do not actually think that
they're a ghost since somebody told you
that apparently
um they just feel like I wonder what
would have made you think that if you
call yourself a ghost why would someone
think that you think you're a ghost
that's a that's a that's mind-boggling
like a cisgender white male [__]
Beyond me but
um they just feel that goesco self is a
perfect way to describe how they feel
about their gender pronoun wise
and it literally yeah she's pissed away
as if you would use somebody's name
instead of a pronoun it works the same
way as talking about somebody in the
third person literally if I were to say
sorry favorite game is a PlayStation 2
game literally and it makes you look
very happy that it still works but then
you replace it with a Neo when they like
I love all in tick tocks they have to
memorize like five words at a time and
then pause pause the video and then I
don't know it's just funny
extremely important and when it makes it
goes she has to get it right because it
still works like it's the same thing in
a different font like for what and you
know what what is what is wrong with he
and she and they like can you just stop
with this this imagine God help us
imagine being a parent so there's we
have the bucket of of parents with these
trans and crazy you know multi-gendered
kids and who the parents made them that
way because the parents are tapped and
they have a lot of screws loose so
they're happy when their kid turns out
to be another Fruit Loop but then you
got the normal parents and there have
been I've been seeing more and more
interviews with these people who their
kids are total Fruit Loops weirdos
mentally
disabled by their their gender or
fluidity or their whatever their trans
status is and their pronouns and those
parents are going through living hell
watching their kids do this first they
start with the phase of I'm just going
to be supportive and I'm going to see
what I can do because I don't want to
push my child away because we know that
if we push our kid too far you know to
try to control them
further close yeah go even further right
yeah all right thank you for helping me
with that so they first try to like you
know put their arms around their kid and
accept it and then they see the kid
losing their minds and going completely
unraveled and then they have to deal
with their kids being on Tick Tock in
this talking about attack crazy
ridiculous utter complete nonsense and
getting applauded for it while also
still being as depressed and anxious or
even more depressed than the things than
before they made this very important
change this is extremely hard on parents
and they can't come out because if they
come out they'll have an higher
Community burning you know with
pitchforks and torches on their front
lawn yeah my my kids aren't and they're
they're suffering not doing this and
these kids don't give a [__] about their
parents or their families they're
selfish very happy because it still
works like it's the same thing in a
different form like can we pass this one
difficult for you to grasp it's such a
simple card and third graders can
understand it how beautiful friends it's
the lesbian Snow White here aka the
pronoun gal and today I'm going to show
you how to use rat rats pronouns and
sentences so let's go red rats like
Ratatouille no these are just Neo
pronouns and I understand how that can
be confusing because you know you've
never heard of them that is such a great
person red smile is so contagious in
fact I saw rat make a whole audience
smile I think rats should be very proud
about a young man knows how to use a yo
who
uh
[Music]
I'd rather riding on the wall won't last
long yeah
[Music]